[MUSIC]
ALEX WHEATLEY: We are at Littlebrook Elementary and we're Reading with the Tigers.
So we're going in, we went in to
kindergarten, first-
and second-grade classes today.
STUDENT READING: Take three,
face the wolf,
and bow deeply,
for ninjas are very polite.
MALLORY REMICK: I actually
read a book called "I'm Bored"
about a potato who's bored, and
we read a book about a shark
and a train, and a unicorn,
and they were --
It was a really cool experience to see
how excited the kids were to read
the stories and hear what's going on,
and interact with the stories,
and tell us about their toys,
and what they would do if they
had a potato.
ALEX WHEATLEY: I had
Ms. Federico's class.
I read "Dylan the Villain."
It was great.
I really enjoyed it.
I got some laughs so
I think it went well.
STUDENT READING: She picked up the tiny thing to consider it more closely.
"Are you a duck?," she asked.
"Quack!"
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE STRAIN: I was in a second-grade
classroom and actually read
the Abbott and Costello bit
"Who's on First?"
At first I was like, are they
gonna get this? I don't know.
But the kids, they loved it, and
every time I got to a new page,
"Oh, I get it, Who is their name!
That's awesome!"
BYRON SANBORN: I was in a
kindergarten classroom
and I was reading a book called
"Shark vs. Train."
It was very exciting.
The kids were delighted.
And I found out that a bunch
of them are avid swimmers,
which was very exciting when they
found out that we were swimmers.
They were all very stoked to tell us about
how great of a swimmer they all were.
ALEX WHEATLEY: They had all sorts
of questions, like,
Who are you going to play?
What was the best game?
How does it feel to be an athlete
at Princeton?
Which are good questions.
But it is fun, and it's --
You know that they come to games
and some of them know me already,
because Ms. Federico's class
is also our pen pal class.
STUDENT READING: June 15.
My school picture came out terrible.
Mom says next time I better have all
my eyes looking in the same direction.
MALLORY REMICK: Princeton has
given athletes so much,
and it's a great opportunity
for us to serve the community,
and give back, and take a little time
out of our day to just be here
for everyone else in this community
that's really done so much for us.
STUDENT READING: And finally,
Duck knew what it was to fly.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX WHEATLEY: I think
Reading with the Tigers
is an amazing example of
"Achieve. Serve. Lead."
It is a chance for us to
directly give back to the community
in a way that we were them
15 years ago,
and look where we are now --
Best school in the nation,
playing the sport we love.
So it's a direct way to give back
to the community and love doing it.